by all the sucks sucks ah
you miss me [ __ ] I'm really happy with
this spot and I see I saw you run past
me there mark Oh chips are on the ground
I hear your footsteps
Wow I wouldn't have known if you moved
it didn't show up on my reticle that you
were you you panic mark what's right at
me with a gun but you panicked
I say you mark in the free range camera
uh space oh not anymore he can't see you
no not anymore wait a minute wait a
minute what well how do you want to do
this wait I don't think you know it's
what he is mark stop there Oh tossing
around the file box is like a loser
wandering around aimlessly like a loser
holding up objects like a loser looking
around confused like a loser I'm gonna
break you you gotta break nobody you
ain't gonna break Oh
what that you didn't like that table
there wait II poop I don't like this are
you kidding me it was a file cabinet in
the corner this is the wrong way was I
facing the wrong way
oh wait walked right by me you're
killing me
[Laughter]
[Music]
wait did you did he kill you yet cease
confiding in grasp that emotional
response there mark what are you in here
SIA are you know stupid [ __ ] you you
know what what I didn't do I I'm not
there what are you talk where are you
where are you don't be digging with me I
hold a lot of stuff people set things
[Laughter]
not a barrel I'm not a barrel I am NOT a
tiny little cup or something that's
really something relatively big actually
for this area you gotta be kidding me
you were flat on the ground I know that
was freaking beautiful went into that
room and stood on me
shut up no I hear it marks the master
most the best master ever
you shut up okay all right I'm in the
office I'll give you that
all right how's it going no that's not
me nope not there either
nope not me I think you're just talking
to tog
no I can see me I don't know who it is I
can see someone oh I'm not that foil box
Oh nope nope nope nope you all look so
stupid
by all I mean both of you all both of us
so dumb really carrying that chair
around is that really what you want to
do did that hurt
no that thing are you some piece of crap
tiny little thing nope I'm big I'm
pretty big birdy
what you may not have considers that I
can see you from a different room I have
honestly no idea can we get like some
sort of clue would you like to take a
seat sit down you all right there is
that is that like a real clue that's a
real that's a legitimate two because you
have no actual obligation to give us
that was wait wait where are you I'm in
the office room with all the flippin
chairs then that's who that is oh wait
do you feel dabbling from all the wrong
targets you have shot no that didn't do
anything how much health do you have to
kill all the chairs oh poor little
weight
well you can't sleep on them teabagging
your corpse I thought I'd be back by the
time you got there damn it there's a
prop stop is that the sound of despair
and discord that I hear wait come over
here
I can't move now there was one more
chair usually mark I'm gonna figure it
out any thoughts sprouting in that - no
I'm not then where are you okay I'm
hitting something I'm not damaging
myself oh well not everything is a prop
is the other problem yeah
Oh where'd you go Bob
where's go you leave me behind yeah I
don't think you're in there oh oh did
you go away I really don't think you're
in there
I see their marks from all this drinking
wait a minute see you running back
towards your spawn point maybe I'll just
go after the easier target of wait I see
you running across the opening there the
ladder I know you don't dig with me I
see you standing around looking like a
[ __ ] dry up go down wait you're doing
fine I see jumping on those boxes that's
my game that's my game I see you having
trouble jumping on a box
oh there I am having trouble jumping by
the way I can't seem to jump correctly
wait a minute so more knocked over this
trashcan huh so you shouldn't hit that
trashcan that does no damage to you for
some reason you sons of [ __ ]
I swear to God see you later mark we're
out mark you were right in front of me
oh god now I'm supposed to dick with you
guys you guys don't dig with me shut up
shut up shut up
[Laughter]
oh I knew you had to be addressed in
okay Bob you're you're out of why you
leave in my office mark why why you
leaving in my office bro
where'd you go you're such a pain to
find are you you what are you tiny
you're a TB TB d don't shut up I swear
to god this is really fun awesome
sure I'm here mark I can see you you're
in this room are you you're in this room
I swear to god you're in this room
probably you're never gonna find me
don't always you shut up yeah why are
you leaving
I swear I'm watching you run directly
away from me you son of a [ __ ] where
are you
you just ran right past me though what
wait a minute I can't even make you see
me from where I am what mark what
where'd you go where'd you go where'd
you go
did you go you're gonna shadow the
shadow angels ever have you shut your
mouth
[Music]